The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In the previous lectures, we
talked about the general
incremental continuum mechanics
equations that we're
using in nonlinear finite
element analysis.
In this lecture, I would like,
now, to talk about the finite
element matrices that we're
using, actually, in static and
dynamic analysis.
You want to talk about these
in quite general terms.
In the next lecture then, we
will talk more about the
details of these matrices.
You want to formulate these
finite element matrices.
And we want to talk about the
numerical integration that we
use to actually evaluate
the matrices.
I've prepared some view graphs
regarding this material.
And I'd like to share the
information on these view
graphs now with you.
The derivation of the finite
element matrices, of course,
is based on the continuum
mechanics equations that we
have developed earlier.
And you have seen this equation
earlier when we
talked about the total
Lagrangian formulation, the
T.L. formulation.
We talked about the terms
in this equation.
We talked about their meaning,
what they stand for.
And we have derived certain
terms here because they have
been obtained by linearization
process.
This was the governing equation
for the total
Lagrangian formulation.
The governing continuum
mechanics equation for the
updated Lagrangian formulation
is shown here.
Once again, we talked about
each of these terms.
We talked about what
their meaning is.
And, of course, we arrived
at this equation by
linearization process.
For the total Lagrangian and
the updated Lagrangian
formulation, we recognized
because of the linearization
process that was involved, we
need to iterate to obtain an
accurate solution to the actual
problem of interest.
And here on this view graph,
I've summarized the iterative
equations that are used in the
total Lagrangian formulation.
We, once again, have seen
this equation before.
We should recognize,
now, these terms.
The iteration count, of course,
being k, as shown here
on the left-hand side
of the equation.
And k minus one on the
right-hand side of the equation.
We also recognize this
equation here, now.
Namely, the equation where we
update the displacements from
the k minus first iteration
to the k iteration.
For this iteration, of course,
we need initial conditions.
And those initial conditions we
also talked about earlier.
A similar equation is used
in the updated Lagrangian
formulation.
These are the terms that we
talked about earlier.
And, of course, once again, we
are iterating with iteration
count of k on the left-hand
side, iteration count of k
minus one on the right-hand
side of the equation.
The displacements are
updated, as shown
here in this equation.
And for this iteration, of
course, we need initial
conditions, which
are given here.
And all of these terms, really,
we discussed in some
detail in the earlier
lectures.
Well, assuming that loading is
deformation-independent, we
also recognize that this here
is the expression for the
external virtual work.
t plus theta tR, the script
R that I talked
about earlier already.
And these are the terms that
we already defined earlier.
Particularly the body force
term, the surface force term.
Notice that, so far, we really
talked about static analysis.
And I'd like to now, of course,
also introduce the
term that we use in
dynamic analysis.
This, of course, is
the inertia term.
And in dynamic analysis, this
is the term that is really
contained in this term here
as an effect of fV.
Of the volume forces, the
forces per unit volume.
Notice that this is really
here an integral over the
volume at time t plus theta t of
the mass density at time t
plus theta t times the
accelerations at time t plus
theta t, the virtual
displacements, and, of course,
the integrating over the
volume at time t plus
[? theta, ?]
t plus theta t, as
I said already.
This is, of course, an
"inconvenient" interval.
Inconvenient in quotes because
we don't know this volume.
So we cannot really directly
evaluate this integral.
Instead we'd rather like to work
with the original volume
like we do in the total
Lagrangian formulation.
And transformation of this
integral to an integral over
the original volume is achieved
by this equation
here, by this term here.
Notice that, of course, 0 rho
times 0 dV for a particular
set of mass particles must be
equal to t plus theta t rho
times t plus theta tdV.
And this is the reason why we
can directly write down this
equation here.
However, considering this
transformation for finite
element analysis, it is
important to realize that we
assume here that the
possibilities of the motion,
of the material particles as
contained in the finite
element interpolations
are the same in this
volume as in that volume.
This fortunately, is true
in isoparametric
finite element analysis.
And therefore, this
transformation from the volume
t plus theta t to the volume
V 0 is a very convenient
transformation to perform for
the evaluation of this term.
We use that abundantly
in isoparametric
finite element analysis.
If the external loads are
deformation-dependent, then we
have to recognize that
these forces here are
deformation-dependent, and
therefore, we have to evaluate
them in the iteration.
And that is being shown
here in this equation.
That we are always evaluating
this term new, depending on
the iteration k minus 1, we
integrate this product here
over the volume at time
t plus theta t in
iteration k minus 1.
Similarly, we update, also,
the surface forces.
Since the surface area changes
of the body during the last
information process, we evaluate
this part here as
shown here.
Of course, there is an
approximation involved.
But if we keep on it iterating
t plus theta tVk minus one,
we'll take on the volume
t plus theta tV.
And of course then, we really
include here the term that we
want to include, namely that
one in the analysis.
Similarly here.
The surface area, in iteration
k minus 1, as k goes larger
and larger.
If we converge, we'll actually
be equal to that surface area,
meaning that this expression is
equal to that expression,
which of course we
want to include.
It's this expression that
we want to include
in the force vector.
We, in one of the very early
lectures, talked about the
materially-nonlinear-only
analysis.
And the equation that is used,
the continuum mechanics
equation that is used in the
materially-nonlinear-only
analysis is given here.
Notice, here we have a stress
strain law tensor, an
incremental strain tensor,
the virtual strain.
The incremental strain
tensor is the real
strain tensor here.
All the components of that
tensor have a superscript k.
The external virtual work.
And here, we have the stress
tensor, components of the
stress tensor.
At time t plus theta t in
iteration k minus 1.
And the virtual strains again.
Notice here now, we do not have
anymore subscripts, 0 or
t, on these components because
in materially-nonlinear-only
analysis, we assume that the
deformations are very small.
The displacements are
infinitesimal.
And the stress, the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress, which
we defined in an earlier lecture
is actually equal to
the Cauchy stress under those
conditions and is equal to the
physical stress that we are
talking about here in the
materially-nonlinear-only
analysis.
In other words, both those
stress measures are equal to
the physical stress that appears
here, which is, of
course, the force
per unit area.
The one that we are so familiar
with in infinitesimal
displacement analysis.
Let us look further at
dynamic analysis.
Dynamic analysis is generally
performed in nonlinear
analysis, using an implicit time
integration scheme or an
explicit time integration
scheme.
And in a later lecture, we
will discuss such time
integration schemes.
In implicit time integration,
we look at the equilibrium
equation at time t plus theta
t to obtain the solution at
time t plus theta t.
And this means that we will
have to evaluate this
left-hand side written here as
given on the right-hand side.
This part here, this external
virtual work, comes from the
external loads that
are not the mass
of the inertia forces.
The inertia forces are taken
care of via this part, via
this integral here,
which I discussed
already a bit earlier.
In explicit time integration,
we are evaluating or we're
looking at the equilibrium
equation at time t to obtain
the solution at time
t plus theta t.
Quite different from implicit
time integration.
And the governing equations are
in the total Lagrangian
formulation right here, in the
U.L., the updated Lagrangian
formulation given here, and in
the materially-nonlinear-only
analysis as given here.
Notice, of course, that R will
involve the inertia forces
evaluated at time t now.
And that will, of course, enable
us to march forward
with a solution as we
will discuss later
on in another lecture.
The finite element equations
corresponding to these
continuum mechanics equations
look as follows.
In materially-nonlinear-only
analysis, let's look first at
static analysis.
We have this basic equation.
Notice a tension stiffness
matrix that does not carry any
subscript 0 or t because we are
talking about the original
volume, the displacements being
infinitesimally small,
the physical stress, no Cauchy
stress really, no second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress needs
to be introduced.
We just talk about the physical
stress that we are so
familiar with in infinitesimal
displacement analysis.
And that, of course, goes into
the evaluation of the K matrix
because the material law will
appear in here, the
incremental displacement vector,
and on the right-hand
side, the load vector, and the
nodal point forces that are
equivalent in the sense of the
principle of virtual work to
the current element stresses.
By current, I mean F time t
plus theta t at the end of
iteration i minus 1.
This equation, of course, looks
very much alike of what
we have seen in the updated
Lagrangian formulation and in
the total Lagrangian
formulation.
In dynamic analysis using
implicit time integration,
this will be the governing
equation.
Now, the mass matrix, the
acceleration vector with an
iteration [? count of ?] i
because we are marching
forward to a situation, to a
configuration which is still
unknown, a tangent stiffness
matrix, the same tangent
stiffness matrix that we see
here, by the way, the
incremental displacement vector,
and on the right-hand
side, the same quantities
that we have here.
In dynamic analysis using
explicit time integration, we
have the mass matrix, the same
mass matrix, generally, that
we have here.
Although in implicit time
integration, we will sometimes
use a lump mass matrix,
sometimes a banded mass
matrix, a consistent
mass matrix.
With an explicit time
integration, we generally use
only the lump mass matrix.
But otherwise, the same
kind of matrix here.
The acceleration vector.
The force vector or the nodal
point forces, corresponding to
time t that are externally
applied to the structure.
And the tF vector, which is the
force vector corresponding
to the stresses in the
elements at time t.
Notice, we are looking here at
equilibrium at time t to
obtain the solution at
time t plus theta t.
We are looking here at
equilibrium, or I should say,
we're iterating for equilibrium
at time
t plus theta t.
And thus, we will obtain
the solution for time
t plus theta t.
In the total Lagrangian
formulation, we have very
similar equations.
In static analysis, a tangent
stiffness matrix, and
otherwise, the same kind of
vectors that I talked about
earlier already.
Notice now, of course, we
have the subscript 0.
Notice also that the total
tangent stiffness matrix is
made up of a part that we might
call a linear strain
stiffness matrix and a part
that we may call nonlinear
strain stiffness matrix.
This is also called the
geometric stiffness matrix.
We will talk about how
we construct these
matrices just now.
In dynamic analysis, we
proceed as in the
material-nonlinear-only
formulation, of course.
And in all the other
formulations, if we use
implicit time integration,
we apply
the equilibrium equation.
We look for the equilibrium
at time t plus theta t, as
expressed here.
And we have vectors, matrices
very similar to what we have
in the material-nonlinear-only
formulation except that once
again, of course, we have now
introduced here the geometric
stiffening affect,
the nonlinear
strain stiffness matrix.
In dynamic analysis using
explicit time integration, we
don't use any K matrix.
We will discuss that also
much more later on.
And this is the governing
equation.
Very much the same as in the
material-nonlinear-only
formulation.
Finally, in the updated
Lagrangian formulation, we
also obtain similar equations
and static analysis.
These are the equations
that we want to solve.
Notice also, the nonlinear
strain to them there or the
nonlinear strain stiffness
matrix.
Otherwise, the matrices and
vectors are very much alike
what we have seen before.
Dynamic analysis implicit time
integration and in dynamic
analysis using explicit
time integration.
Notice that in each of these, we
are always cutting out the
subscript t or t plus theta t
the way I have been talking
about earlier already.
We have seen this equation,
of course, before
in our earlier lectures.
What we now do is we introduce
the mass terms.
And we are talking about
implicit time integration and
explicit time integration.
We should note that these
equations are valid for single
finite element as
well as for an
assemblage of finite elements.
If we have a large number of
elements, then, of course, we
would assemble these as we do it
in linear elastic analysis
using the direct stiffness
method.
Considering an assemblage of
elements, we will see that
different formulations may be
used in different regions of
the structure.
In other words, schematically
here we may have some elements
that are governed by the T.L.,
the total Lagrangian
formulation, some others by
the updated Lagrangian
formulation, and some others by
the material-nonlinear-only
formulation.
Notice that compatibility
between these elements is, of
course, perfectly preserved if
these are compatible elements
as shown here.
Then, there is nothing wrong
with using the U.L.
formulation for certain elements
that are bordering
elements with another
formulation such as this.
It is not true, for example,
that due to the fact that
you're using here different
kinds of formulations, you are
getting an incompatibility
introduced here.
I've heard that sometimes.
That is certainly not
my understanding
of the subject matter.
It does not matter whether
you have the same kind of
formulations or two different
kind of formulations.
That will not effect the
compatibility between two elements.
Let us now concentrate on
the derivation or on the
formulation of a single
element matrix.
To obtain a single element
matrices, we have to
introduce, of course, an
interpolation matrix.
And this matrix interpolates
the internal element
displacements via the nodal
point displacements.
Here, I'm showing a full node
element with these nodal point
displacements.
Notice these are measured in
the Cartesian coordinate
directions.
Notice however, that these nodal
point displacements are
measured into a skewed
direction, an a
b coordinate system.
There's nothing wrong with
introducing different systems
because this is Q system at the
different nodal points.
The nodal point vector, the
vector of nodal point degrees
of freedom is listed here.
Notice that vector carries a hat
to denote the fact that it
contains this great nodal
point displacements.
Notice also, that the subscripts
1, 2 refer to the
Cartesian coordinate
directions for the
superscripts referred
to the nodal point.
Here 1, 2 again.
3 denoting the nodal point.
Notice up here, a b, of course
refer to the skewed
directions.
And the 1 refers to
the nodal point 1.
We want to interpolate the
internal displacements in
terms of the nodal point
displacements.
And that is being achieved by
this relationship here.
U, the internal particle
displacements are given via H,
the displacement interpolation
matrix times U hat.
U hat being this vector, the
one we just discussed.
U being a vector of these
two displacements.
Now, notice that these two
displacements, of course,
depend on which particle
you are looking at.
Here, a particular particle.
This would be the displacement
you want.
That's the displacement U2.
And these displacements vary
over the element, which would
be expressed by this H matrix.
These are the nodal point
displacements.
These are the varying,
continuously varying
displacements of the particles
within the element.
We will, of course, use this
kind of relationship now quite
extensively.
We have, of course, also already
encountered this
relationship in linear
elastic analysis.
Let us now see how we
are formulating
the different matrices.
For all analysis types, in
which we want to include
inertia forces, we evaluate this
integral as shown here.
Notice the displacements and
accelerations are interpolated
via this relationship here.
For the accelerations, of
course, we would have dots
here, dots there denoting
second time derivatives.
And we would have t plus theta
t as a superscript on each of
these variables.
Notice that we also use this
interpolation here for the
virtual displacements.
And the result is given right
here just like in linear
elastic analysis.
The right inside load vector
as evaluated is shown here.
Once again, we introduce
interpolation for U or for the
virtual displacements and the
virtual surface displacements.
This interpolation here
gives us this H
matrix, H transpose matrix.
This here interpolated gives
us the HST matrix.
Notice that HS is the
interpolation matrix for the
surface displacements
as a function of--
or rather it gives the surface
displacements I should say as
a function of the nodal
point displacements.
So HS is really evaluated by
using H, the H matrix I just
talked about, and evaluating
that H matrix on the surface
of the element.
That is how you get HS.
And all of this expression
together
gives us the load vector.
As a matter of fact it is
really the same process
followed that we are using
in linear infinitesimally
displacement analysis.
In material-nonlinear-only
analysis, considering an
incremental displacement UI, we
evaluate this integral here
as shown here.
Notice here the virtual
displacements that are coming
in because we have the virtual
strains there.
Notice here the real
displacements, which are
coming in from these
real strains.
Of course, these are strain
increments and,
correspondingly, displacement
increments.
Nodal point displacement
increments always.
These B matrices, BL matrices,
are obtained by evaluating the
strains from the nodal
point displacements.
And, of course, the
interpolation that is used for
the element goes in here.
The B matrix, of course,
contains derivatives of the
elements of the H matrix.
A vector containing components
of eIj is this one here.
For example, in two dimensional
plane stress
analysis, the entries in this
vector are listed right here.
Notice that there is a 2 here
because e12 is equal to e21.
And the sum of these two,
of course, gives us
a total sheer strain.
And therefore, we simply
put a 2 times e12 here.
This evaluation is performed
much in the same way as in
linear infinitesimal
displacement analysis.
Except that we have to remember
this stress tensor,
this stress strain tensor,
this considerative tensor
varies in the incremental
solution because we have
materially nonlinear
conditions.
So the K matrix here
will change.
And that is indicated, of
course, by the t up there.
Notice the B matrix, in this
incremental analysis, using
the material-nonlinear-only
formulations is constant.
For the material-nonlinear-only
formulation, we also want to
evaluate the F vector.
And that F vector is a result
of this integral here.
We take this integral,
interpolate the virtual strains.
And that is this part here, in
terms of the virtual nodal
point displacements.
And we assemble in this vector
here capital sigma at time t,
the stresses t sigma ij.
We assemble those
in this vector.
Notice, in two dimensions
analysis, this vector is given
down here as these components.
By the way, no two here.
You should think about that.
There should be no two here.
Total Lagrangian formulation.
We have similarly an
integral as in the
material-nonlinear-only
formulation.
We interpolate, once again,
these real incremental
strains, the virtual strains.
And the result is directly
given here.
With the B matrix, now,
defined via this
equation down here.
And, of course, this vector here
contains the components
of the incremental
strain tensor.
However, in the total Lagrangian
formulation, we
know also have an additional
integral.
And that integral is coming in
because of the geometric
stiffening effect of the
nonlinear strain term effect.
Here we have the integral.
And the discretization
is given on the
right-hand side here.
Notice this is a BNL matrix,
nonlinear strain
matrix, we call it.
This here is a matrix of the
second Piola-Kirchhoff
stresses at time t.
And here we have, again,
the BNL matrix.
This product together gives
us the KNL matrix.
One might ask how do you
get these quantities?
Well, actually we construct
this S matrix and the BNL
matrix such that when you take
the product of this whole
right-hand side, you get that.
So these matrices are really
constructed such as to obtain
what we need to get.
And that is this part here.
I will show you later
on specific
examples in another lecture.
Here we have the S
matrix containing
components as I've mentioned.
And this matrix here times
this vector contains the
components of this displacement
derivative.
The right-hand side, of
course, for the total
Lagrangian formulation has the
evaluation of the F vector.
And that one is obtained
from this integral.
Notice we go over.
We evaluate this integral by
this relationship here.
The linear strain displacement
matrix goes in here.
And a vector of the second
Piola-Kirchhoff
stresses goes in here.
Once again, this vector is
constructed in such a way that
this right-hand side here is
equal to that integral.
In the updated Lagrangian
formulation, we proceed much
in the same way.
Considering incremental
displacement UI, we have this
integral to evaluate.
We interpolate the strains via
the strain-displacement
[? interpolation ?] matrix, and
the result is this here.
This is here the linear strain
stiffness matrix.
Here we have a relation very
much alike of what we have in
the total Lagrangian
formulation for the
incremental strains.
The nonlinear strain stiffness
matrix in the updated
Lagrangian formulation is also
very much evaluated like in
the total Lagrangian
formulation.
It is this integral that
we now have to capture.
And we do so by constructing a
BNL matrix, a tall matrix,
such that this total
product here is
equal to this integral.
And what's underlined here in
blue is the matrix that we're
looking for.
We should, of course, also
evaluate in the updated
Lagrangian formulation
the F vector.
And that F vector, which appears
on the right-hand side
of the equation in the updated
Lagrangian formulation, is
evaluated by calculating
this integral.
Notice that this is obtained
by this right-hand side.
The BL, of course, is
the linear strain
displacement matrix.
And here we have a vector, tall
hat, which contains the
stresses, Cauchy the
stresses at time t.
It's constructed such that this
integral here, with this
part in front of it, gives
us exactly that integral.
And what is underlined here in
blue is the actual F vector
that we're looking for.
So what we have seen then, is
that the finite element
matrices for the
material-nonlinear-only, the
total Lagrangian, and the
updated Lagrangian formulation
are formulated by looking
at the individual volume
integrals in these continuum
mechanics formulations.
And by interpolating the
displacements and strains much
in the same way as we are used
to in linear analysis.
Once we have formulated these
matrices, we, of course, have
to evaluate them.
And that is done using numerical
integration, once
again, just very similar
to what we're
doing in linear analysis.
We're using, primarily, Gauss
integration or Newton-Cotes
integration.
Schematically, in
two-dimensional analysis, the
K matrix would be evaluated
as shown here.
Notice that in isoparametric
finite element analysis, we
are integrating from minus 1
to plus 1 over the domain.
Two-dimensional analysis,
of course, two
integrations involved.
That we have a B matrix
transposed, C matrix, B here,
a determinant of a Jacobian
matrix, which comes in because
we are transforming from the x1,
x2 space to the RS space.
And we call that the G matrix's
total product.
And the numerical integrations
then really involves nothing
else but summing a product
of alpha ij, Gij over all
numerical integration points.
Notice the ij here now refers to
the ij's integration point.
This is what we are doing also
in linear analysis and in
nonlinear analysis as well.
Similarly, we would evaluate
the F vector, which, of
course, we have in the
material-nonlinear-only, total
Lagrangian, or updated
Lagrangian formulation as
shown here.
Notice, once again,
integration from
minus 1 to plus 1.
And this part here is what
we might call G again.
F then, is obtained
as shown here.
Of course these are the
integration point weights that
are given to us, which we
simply use in the finite
element solution.
The mass matrix is evaluated
as shown here.
Mass density goes in there.
H transpose H. H, of course,
being the displacement
interpolation matrix.
And this is our G here.
With that G, we should put a bar
under that G here because
it's a matrix.
You put it in.
And if we use that G here
in this formula,
we get the M matrix.
So the numerical integration
is really performed much in
the way as we're doing it
in linear analysis.
Frequently, we use Gauss
integration,
as I mentioned earlier.
And, as a typical example, 3x3
into Gauss integration is
schematically shown here.
Here is our element.
Here is the R coordinate axes.
Here is the s coordinate axes.
This would be the integration
point stations that we are
using for 3x3 integration.
The r and s values are
given as shown here.
Same r and s values as
in linear analysis.
And we notice that these
integration point stations are
all within the element.
That is, of course, one
feature off the Gauss
integration.
As I mentioned earlier they
use also Newton-Cotes
integration, for example for
the integration through the
shell's thickness.
Here is the r direction, which
is a coordinate axis in the
mid-surface of the shell.
And s goes through
the thickness.
Notice here we have five point
Newton-Cotes integration.
And that some integration
points, as a matter of fact
two here, are actually on the
surface of the element.
Because we are including the
surface of the element, we use
Newton-Cotes integration
quite frequently
in nonlinear analysis.
The reason being that if we do
an elasto-plastic analysis, we
find that the larger stresses,
of course, are generally
generated on the surfaces
of the element.
And these are then also the
areas where plasticity sets in
earliest, which means that
we want to pick up this
elasto-plastic response as
quickly as possible.
And integration point stations
on the surface of the element
can be of benefit.
If you compare Gauss with
Newton-Cotes integration, we
recognize that with n Gauss
points, we integrate a
polynomial of order 2n minus 1
exactly, meaning, for example,
with two Gauss points, you
integrate a cubic exactly and
everything below
it, of course.
Whereas with n Newton-Cotes
points, we integrate only a
polynomial of n minus
1 exactly.
So we need really many more
Newton-Cotes integration
points to pick up the same
accuracy in the integration as
you do with the Gauss
point integration.
For this reason, we use,
primarily really, the Gauss
integration, particularly in
the analysis of solids.
Maybe a big, chunky bodies
where there is no need,
really, to pick up the plastic
response say on the surface
directly of the solid.
Newton-Cotes integration
involves points on the
boundaries.
I mentioned that already.
And therefore, this integration
scheme is
effective for structural
elements for the reasons that
I just gave.
In principle, the integration
schemes I employed as in
linear analysis.
The integration order must be
high enough not to have any
spurious energy modes
in the elements.
We will get back to that in
later lectures, particularly
when we talk about structural
elements, beam elements, and
shell elements.
This is a very important
point.
The appropriate integration
order in nonlinear analysis
can sometimes be higher than
in linear analysis, for
example, to model the plasticity
accurately, once
again, in a shell solution
or such type of analysis.
On the other hand, a too high
integration order is also not
of value because remember, that
the maximum displacement
variation, therefore, the
maximum strain variation you
can pick up, is of course, given
by the interpolation
you're using.
So it doesn't make much sense
to go up in very high
integration order in order
to try to pick up a high
variation in strains, plastic
strains, and the corresponding
stresses, of course.
It doesn't make sense to do that
when you are limited by
the actual strain variation
anyway due to the
interpolations on the
displacements that you're using.
Let me show you an example here
that demonstrates some of
the points that I'm
trying to make.
Here we have an eight node
element that models the
response of a cantilever
and the bending moment.
We measure the rotation
phi here.
We have here the
material data.
Notice we are talking about an
elasto-plastic material with
yield stress.
And we apply a bending
moment as shown here.
In linear elastic analysis,
you would get the exact
response to this problem using
one eight node element.
You might have tried
it already.
You may know that.
The reason, of course, being
that this element contains a
parabolic displacement
interpolation, which is the
analytical solution
to this problem.
And therefore, you get
the exact solution.
In elasto-plastic analysis,
however, the solution depends
on the integration order
we are using.
And this is demonstrated
on this view graph.
Here we show on the vertical
axis, the moment normalized to
the moment at first yield.
And on the horizontal axis,
the rotation of the beam
normalized to the rotation at
first yield, respectively.
Now, notice that the linear
elastic response, of course,
would be simply this line here
going up vertically.
In elasto-plastic analysis,
however, the
element starts yielding.
And the yield is picked up,
depending on the integration
order you're using.
With 2 by 2 integration, we
get this solution here.
And this would be
the limit load.
With 3 by 3 integration, we
get this solution for the
limit load.
And with 4 by 4 integration,
we get this solution as a
limit load.
So this solution very much
depends on the integration
order that you're using.
And it shows here that we need
enough integration point
stations through the thickness
of the beam in order to
approximate, appropriately,
the limit load
that we want to calculate.
Let me show you another
problem.
And this is an interesting
problem in which we want to
design a numerical experiment to
test whether an element can
undergo properly large,
rigid body motions.
Here we consider a single
two-dimensional four node element.
It could be plain stress
or plain strain.
And we want to test by a
numerical experiment that you
can perform on a computer
program, whether this element
can actually perform
large, rigid body
motions, of course, properly.
And by properly, I mean there
should be no stresses
generated in the element when it
is subjected to these rigid
body motions.
Well, there are for this element
three rigid body
motions of interest.
Two translations and
one rotation.
It's a two-dimensional
element, so these two
translations, of course, refer
to the horizontal translation
and the vertical translation.
The rotation, of course, refers
to the rotation in the
two-dimensional plane.
To test whether the element
can undergo properly the
horizontal rigid body motion,
we designed this numerical
experiment.
We put here to truss elements.
We call them M.N.O. trusses
because they do not include
then any geometric
nonlinearalities.
They are really just springs.
And we put this element
on a roller here.
Keep it otherwise free.
And we put onto this degree of
freedom a load, R. And on that
degree of freedom a
load, R, as well.
The load is very large.
So the element should move over
stress free by a very
large amount.
This is one rigid body movement
that the fall out
element must, of course,
be able to undergo.
And this test is passed for the
T.L., U.L., and the M.N.O,
or linear analysis, of course.
Similarly, we could perform
this test for
the vertical direction.
And we would find that, once
again, the T.L., U.L.
formulation, and M.N.O.
formulation will pass a test
for the vertical direction
as well.
The interesting test is the
one for the rotation.
Here we have our fall out
element supported at the
left-hand side by a pin, and on
the right-hand side by an
M.N.O. truss.
Once again, a truss element
that does not model any
geometric nonlinearalities.
We are applying to this node
here a force, R, that would,
of course, make this element
here go through the rotation.
Since the force should be
taken in the spring, the
element should rotate
stress free.
Note that because this spring
is and M.N.O. spring, the
force acting onto this node
here must always work
vertically only.
After the load is applied, the
element, originally here, must
have rotated by a very
large amount.
The area must have
not changed.
In other words, the element
size must remain constant.
And the element must
be stress free.
This test is passed by the by
the U.L., and the T.L., the
total Lagrangian formulations,
by the updated Lagrangian, and
the total Lagrangian formations
properly.
But if you were to use the
material-nonlinear-only
formulation, you would see that
this element does not
remain or keep its
original size.
The reason being that this node
here will move up on this
side here because of the
M.N.O. truss there.
We move up here.
And all of the element remain
stress free, the element
actually grows in size.
It's an interesting test that
you can actually perform on a
computer program.
Once again, the total Lagrangian
and the updated
Lagrangian formulations, which,
of course, are designed
to more large quotations and
large strains pass this test
properly, whereas the M.N.O.
Formulation, which is not
designed to model large
quotations, would not pass
this test property.
Well, in this lecture, I've
been trying to give you an
overview of the general element
matrices that we need
in the U.L., T.L., and
M.N.O. formulations.
In the next lectures, we will
derive these element matrices
in detail for different
types of elements.
Thank you very much for
your attention.